the accusations of complacency and
misjudgment has spread across four pages
the headline a damning assessment of
government failure to prepare the quotes
allege five weeks of missed
opportunities and political inertia the
British government's national crisis
committee is called by the acronym Cobra
Prime Minister Boris Johnson's failure
to attend any of the first five
coronavirus cobra meetings is singled
out for particular criticism government
ministers reject The Sunday Times
allegations the idea that the Prime
Minister skipped meetings that were
vital to our response to the coronavirus
I think is good tasks the truth is that
the there are meetings across government
some which are chaired by the health
secretaries on which are chaired by
other ministers but the Prime Minister
took all the major decisions and I think
anyone who considered what happened to
the Prime Minister just a little while
ago nobody can say that the practice
some throwing heart and soul into
fighting this virus an unnamed senior
adviser to Downing Street is quoted in
The Sunday Times as saying this there's
no way you're at war if your PM isn't
there he liked his country breaks he
didn't work weekends there was a real
sense that he didn't do urgent crisis
planning and a senior source at the
Department of Health is also quoted
saying this a pandemic was always at the
top of our national risk register always
but when it came we just slowly watched
for Prime Minister from the moment that
it became clear that there were
challenges in terms of coronavirus
developing in in China has absolutely
been leading our nation's effort to
combat the corona virus making sure that
resources and money is not an issue or a
concern for any department especially
the Health Service in terms of dealing
with this as Britain's start their fifth
week of partial lockdown
the government is firefighting
criticisms from several angles concerns
are growing the frontline medical staff
are running desperately low on supplies
of protective masks and surgical gowns
National Health Service Providers warned
on Friday that stocks may run out within
48 hours the government said 84 tons of
that equipment would arrive on Sunday
from Turkey
the shipment now won't arrive as planned
care home groups are also saying that a
lack of testing means the true scale of
deaths and infections among the elderly
are being seriously underestimated by
the government with more than 4,000
fatalities not officially accounted for
Paul Brennan al Jazeera Westminster